hello battle fielders Aaron Sampson here
to tell you why you should listen to
your command Manning around the map and
a little green icon appears from nowhere
do you a shrink and tear be recite prose
to it or see shut your yapper and go to
the designated spot if you answered C
then you understand that a benevolent
presence called the commander who has
much better situational awareness than
you has committed your insignificant ass
to go take care of an objective the
commander in case you missed it unlocks
at level 10 and can be accessed from
here in battle log or from here in game
through continuous UAV scans the
commander knows what's going on on
almost any objective in the map can tell
you where the enemy team is what they're
doing turn off their ability to 3d spot
and even launch gunships and cruise
missiles depending on the map let's
start with the basics and work our way
to the tricky and deadly the commander
mode gives above all outs situational
awareness this is what the map looks
like from the ground and this is what it
looks like to a commander the commander
can take in the entire map or zoom in
and watch gunfights from a satellite
view UAV scans can be used every few
seconds and reveal enemy troops and
vehicles within an objective sized area
except for lone Wolf's on the enemy team
the commander more or less knows where
everyone is on the map and especially if
they're making a hard push for any given
objective so the first thing a commander
must do is tell you where to go and in
what numbers they do it with this
triangle icon and it looks like this to
a ground level soldier soldiers can and
should confirm the order through the
Comoros because points the commander can
use this simple tool to tell your armor
where the enemy armor is can say go tell
a lone recon player to capture a far
objective to draw the enemy away or tell
players where that obnoxious spawn
beacon is hiding and so on a good tip
for the commander is to occasionally
tell players to go where they're already
going and pick up some easy points along
the way as players do what they've been
told in cap objectives your commander
powers grow in one of three directions
the top tree is all about more
situational awareness this tree also
lets you start fighting against the
enemy commander the EMP power blinds an
area for the opposing commander
down 3d spotting for enemy soldiers and
is rumored to be able to damage the
ac-130 on the enemy team the bottom tree
in the commander screen reaches down to
squad commanders and allows you to issue
orders promote them give them faster
response or bless them with an ATV or
supply crate typically ATVs are only
helpful on maps such as rogue
transmission where your team might have
to make a long initial run supply crates
on the other hand allow players to
change classes drop one next to a player
do in jackal and encourage them to
switch to engineer and do something
useful or even better drop them on the
heads of enemy recon players and watch
them go splat you don't really get
credit for the kill but I do guarantee a
warm fuzzy feeling speaking of let's
talk about killing as the commander the
tree to the right of the commander tool
employs deadly weapons and mass sweeps
of the map for enemy soldiers and
vehicles these abilities are based
entirely on your team capping specific
objectives see the required objective to
the left of the commander screen for the
most part UAV scans make larger sweeps
redundant but they're good if you feel
like you've lost focus on the flow of
the overall battle and maybe a good
first grab to see what the enemy is up
to right away the weapon on the far
right is another story on sub maps this
gives you a gun ship and on others a
cruise missile in our opinion the gun
ships a little better deal since it's
manned by players and orbits the
battlefield until it's shot down tell
your team when you've deployed one and
which objectives to shoot at first a
team without a commander won't get the
gunship even if they cap the objective
the cruise missile is the other weapon
you get and may look pretty but it can
be blocked by enemy commanders fairly
easily with proxy attacks give teams
ample warning to aback the area and
generally kills fewer people than you
might think it's mostly good at clearing
bases by getting enemies to fight their
intimidation make sure to zoom in all
the way and enjoy your work
so let's put this all together you have
a squad heading for capture point you
need to take you've been saving up your
commander points and are ready to rock
from on high you launch a UAV scan and
realize the base is crawling with enemy
soldiers you decide to commit a nearby
tank in several squad commanders as they
approach you proxy attack the enemy
commander so they can't warn their
players you EMP the objective to shut
down 3d spotting and then give your
squad lightning-fast response or
promotions to bolster their
effectiveness just before they enter the
base you bring up a cruise missile to
focus enemy attention on fleeing or you
get an ac-130 in the air and draw their
attention to the sky by the time the
enemy commander comes back online the
objective is yours and so are a ton of
points so next time you see that little
green objective marker appear in your
view nut up confirm the order and sally
forth knowing an invisible sky man has
your back
enemies just communication
you